-Performing his hit song
"Daylight,"
please welcome David Kushner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Telling myself
I won't go there ♪
♪ Oh, but I know
that I won't care ♪
♪ Tryna wash away all the blood
I've spilt ♪
♪♪
♪ This lust is a burden
that we both share ♪
♪ Two sinners can't atone
from a lone prayer ♪
♪ Souls tied, intertwined by
our pride and guilt ♪
♪♪
♪ There's darkness
in the distance ♪
♪ From the way
that I've been livin' ♪
♪ But I know I can't resist it ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same time ♪
♪ You and I drink the poison
from the same vine ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same time ♪
♪ Hidin' all of our sins
from the daylight ♪
♪ From the daylight,
runnin' from the daylight ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same time ♪
♪ Tellin' myself
it's the last time ♪
♪ Can you spare any mercy that
you might find ♪
♪ If I'm down on
my knees again? ♪
♪ Deep down, way down, Lord,
I try ♪
♪ Try to follow your light,
but it's night time ♪
♪ Please, don't leave me
in the end ♪
♪♪
♪ There's darkness
in the distance ♪
♪ I'm beggin' for forgiveness ♪
♪ But I know I might resist it,
oh ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same time ♪
♪ You and I drink the poison
from the same vine ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same time ♪
♪ Hidin' all of our sins
from the daylight ♪
♪ From the daylight,
runnin' from the daylight ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same tiiiiime ♪
at the same time ♪
♪ You and I drink the poison
from the same vine ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same time ♪
♪ Hidin' all of our sins
from the daylight ♪
♪ From the daylight,
runnin' from the daylight ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same tiiiiime ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
♪ From the daylight,
runnin' from the daylight ♪
♪ Oh, I love it and I hate it
at the same tiiiiime ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoo! Come on!
That's how you do it, buddy.
Thank you so much.
That's how you do it
right there.
David Kushner.
"Daylight" is out now.